late start welcome to this video good
master aviso this is Cora to leav I
think coral to left now probably
butchering this pronunciation this is a
2600 guy really strong strong GM so I'm
going for Kings Indian let's see how he
punishes me for this risky opening might
might happen okay is playing the h3 line
the monk agalloch variation something
that I played myself quite a bit let's
see maybe G for you this is the way they
normally play it and for once I tried to
be quick Yemen
yeah sometimes wonder if I should really
try for those commentary games to to
consciously play quicker I mean it's
it's really that for the commentary I'm
I'm almost done yeah I am slowing down
now that's it's really like that to get
more stuff explained and sometimes I
wonder really if I should just do it
just play quick out and get them and
yeah just squat a little bit a little
bit more because I'm not that that is
slow play actually ok interesting unite
age 44 Bishop h5 and maybe night g6
check hmm maybe interesting way to play
94 though takes takes Bishop h5 yea my
queen doesn't have many squares it's
really a problem hmm ok
yeah maybe yeah this is this is really
really sharp if i take here now are you
guys isn't going to kill me with nijah
six check takes bishop Teague's maybe
you Kim it's now or get seven I don't
know if I give if i go to d7 not just
exchequer takes takes it's difficult to
manage files it's almost made okay seven
yeah maybe I have to give the exchange
if you just takes f7 now I'm perfectly
okay but 96 sister is the problem maybe
I wanted to go ki GA then check 97's
sitting takes Bishop takes for Queen age
five is probably losing can't believe
I'm surviving that night is seven
teenager honey
check
and maybe I could have played Queen
takes e7 the Queen sec it really was it
was a possibility it really was ok so
maybe here long castles I have Queen a
form maybe without calculating too much
maybe between 27 that's not totally
ridiculous I just like a little bit of
coordination okay that that I'm not too
worried about you can take see it
unfortunately the night is a bit
stranded I think you should take unless
he gets 96 in with with great effect
and yeah I think you should take on see
it
where is this something technical Bishop
age six or something for you create no
that's not going to work it's not going
to work
he's taking some time maybe not really
believing that I'm still in the game
somehow yeah but I really don't this is
working I don't believe it check because
of Queen yet but anyway if I'm going
here is moving the king
I can start with a check here actually
I'm Kim Ji Sung can maybe kingdom one is
right actually we had can you one for
King see to wear so that sets a way to
go
should g7 the check is not the prom king
see to this year for King group g1 don't
get in there I've night at forum and I
can still get the check why
night f/4g 6 took me ages to see this
idea
f-for Bishop f5 check is the point his
Queen has no squares check check came I
wonder I can he my probably cannot play
for win here probably not he's trying LH
pony Sam is a problem of course should
be seven-time morning bishop en maybe
check check yeah I have to set my hopes
on the e born I know crap sorry
blundering this pawn was a bad idea
blundering exactly this pawn yeah a
stupid stupid stupid check check check
nah but yay druke is hanging so King
King takes my rook is singing I cannot
play tonight result I didn't see it
didn't see it wow what a game I can just
taking these three and win haha how
lucky is that they can just take this
Lucas hey was check I think oh my god no
I'm not what a game yeah talk talk about
a complete mess yeah so let's let's
let's have a look at this he really
played this is very aggressively yeah
this is me fear with bishop age five
okay i just say show me and probably
probably i am in trouble so he went
bishop age five immediately also could
have taken first now but ok it's it's
probably probably right okay it took c3
yeah I guess difficult to analyze that
and this one okay what's clear is to
start with the easy things this is just
good for black hair I'm stopping the
check here and I have a really nice
position you f-f-for coming night comes
Bishop e7 this is very nice for the
exchange the computer is actually saying
black wins outright which is a bit
surprising but i thought i would be
would be in really good shape so that's
true 96 ever does win and what is
winning bishop h6 is killing me okay oh
yeah okay this looks great ok this is
check this is losing check check check
yeah and finally I'm getting killed I
don't have the time to coordinate my
pieces bishop age 6 was was a killer but
ok those kind of moves the computer sees
this is instantly and of course this guy
also would play it with time on the
clock but Jack you have to make a move
yeah this police wins as well by the way
yeah i was thinking actually i play to
play this then this now but this isn't
this is this kind of sacrifice is not
not totally idiotic it's just a matter
of time if i have a bit of time here
this this is not bad yeah i have a very
nice square on c5 and compact structure
but my king is still i mean for example
just to make a point them if if there
would be G pawns on the board yeah like
I had 15 on g6 he has a pawn on g2 and
okay I cannot take the bishop yeah like
just G pawns without the gphi dope and
then black would have excellent
compensation for the queen but here the
g file is probably killing me ok i went
here and
he can actually do this and still win
because I cannot take this is
immediately over and after 96 I have to
go back and then again this kills me ok
this one yet here this is actually equal
check yeah it should be kept be a draw
and Bishop a very elated right and here
i can get the advantage it seems the
computer wants to take f2 and adri just
grab stuff ok I didn't see that I was
glad to have seen that this is kind of
covering things but here here why does
actually winning with King d2 and then
March the age porn of the board ok ok
kind of lost lost nerves him yeah I have
no move and if I yeah well I cannot I
cannot move my pieces and he's pushing
the pawn yeah white wins she is very
difficult to play this kind of position
correctly this is right ok shaggy ok now
I had this idea to use my my pawns but I
completely overlooked that you can just
take a 4 of course I can just take him
check yea struggling I have no time and
check here yeah Queen g6 was winning ok
I have to have to be quick and of course
this is interesting care this move is
this is not right this is actually a
draw according to the comp amazing so
black has enough counter play against
the king check
this is giving me enough counterplay
amazing yeah yeah it's it's really you
having this Rukia fate is still good but
I really blundered yeah i blundered this
I didn't see that I was like wow I'm
winning here e 2 and my porn but I
didn't see that this anger was checked
but he also didn't see it and just
resigned so what the funny game who ok
thanks for watching